welcome to your round 3 recap of the  sink filled cup the strongest chess  tournament in history well round 3 was a  barnburner seeing three victories but  the key matchup was between world number  one Magnus Carlsen and world number two  in the live rankings fabiano caruana was  leading the tournament with a perfect 2  n.o things just went very well from the  opening and in general things have gone  very well for me here Carson sacrificed  a piece only to see Caruana accepted and  defend coolly and rebuff his attack only  to get to this position where he played  the move rook to d1 check after a  blunder by carlson and wrapped up the  game in simple style my play was not so  great today but let's not draw too many  conclusions yet join us for Round four  coverage of the same field cup here in  st. Louis at 150 central 250 Eastern at  us chess champs calm